the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I'm going to tell you about flux
of a vector field for a curve so you
know in case you have seen flux in
physics or you've seen flux in space and
we're going to come to that in a couple
of weeks but for now we are still doing
everything in the plane so you know bear
with me if you've seen a more
complicated version of flux we're going
to do the easy one first so what is flux
well flux it's actually another kind of
line integral so let's say that I have a
plane curve and the vector field in the
plane then the flux of F across the
curve C is by definition it's a line
integral that I will use not I will use
notation F dot n D s so I have to
explain to you what it means but let me
first box that because that's the
important formula to remember that's the
definition so what does that mean so
first I mean I have mostly I have to
tell you what is this little n so n
connotation suggests you know it's a
normal vector so what does what does
that mean so I have a curve in the plane
and I have a vector field
see vector field will be yellow today
and I will want to integrate along the
curve the dot product of F with the
normal vector to the curve a unit normal
vector to the curve so that means a
vector that's at every point of the
curve perpendicular to the curve and of
length 1 so n everywhere will be the
unit normal vector to the curve C
pointing 90 degrees clockwise
Ponty so what does that mean that means
you know I have two normal vectors one
that's pointing this way when that's
pointing that way I have to choose the
convention and the convention is that
the normal vector that I take goes to
the height of the curve as I'm traveling
along the curve so imagine that you're
walking along this curve then you look
to your height that's that direction
okay so what we will do is we'll just at
every point along the curve we'll do the
dot product between the vector field and
the normal vector and we'll sum that
along the various pieces of a curve so
what this notation means is that if we
actually break C into small pieces of
length Delta s then the flux will be the
limit as the pieces become smaller and
smaller of the son of F dot n Delta s
where you know so I take each small
piece of my curve
I do the dot product between F and n and
I multiply by the length of a piece and
then I add these together that's what
the line integral means of course that's
again not how I will compute it so just
to compare this with work see
conceptually it's similar to the line
integral we did for work except well the
line integral for work so sorry
work is the line integral of F dot d R
which is also the line integral of F dot
T DS that's how we formulated it that
means you know we take our curve and we
figure out at each point how big the
tangent component I guess I should
probably take the same vector field as
before so let's see my field was
pointing monic that way so what I do at
any point is I project F to the tangent
direction and I figure out how much F is
going along my curve and then I sum
these things together so you know I'm
actually summing oh right color the
tangential component
of my field f okay so roughly speaking
the work measures you know when I move
in on my curve how much I'm going with
or against F flags on the other hand
measures when I go along the curve
roughly how much the field is going
across the curve counting positively
what goes to the right negatively what
goes to the left
okay so flux is integral of f dot NDS
and that one corresponds to summing the
normal component of the vector field
okay but apart from that conceptually
it's the same kind of thing just for
physical interpretations will be very
different but for mathematician these
are two line integrals that you set up
compute pretty much in the same way
so let's see I should probably tell you
what means you know why do we make this
definition what does it correspond to so
the interpretation for work made a lot
of sense when F was representing a force
then the line integral was actually the
work done by the force the
interpretation for flux makes more sense
if you think of F as a velocity field
okay so what's the interpretation let's
say that F 4 F a velocity field so that
means you know I'm thinking of some
fluid that's moving maybe water or
something and it's moving at a certain
speed and my vector field represents how
things are moving at every point of the
plane so I claim that flux measures how
much fluid passes full over curve see
per unit time
so if you imagine that you know maybe
you have a river and you're somehow
building a dam here but you know then
we've holes in it with the water still
passes for then this measures how much
water passes for your membrane per unit
time okay let's try to figure out why
this is true why does this make sense so
let's look at what happens on a small
portion of our key of C so I'm zooming
in on makeup C so - I need to zoom
further okay so you know that's a little
piece of my curve of length Delta s and
there's a fluid flow so on my picture
things are flowing to the right so here
I'm drawing a constant vector field
because you know if you zoom in enough
then your vectors will pretty much be
the same everywhere right if you you
know in larger picture enough and things
will be pretty much a uniform flow so
now how much stuff goes for this little
piece of curve got unit time well what
happens over time the fluid is moving
while my curve is staying in the same
place so guys wants to something like
this okay
so I claim that what goes for C in unit
time is actually going to be it's
actually going to be a parallelogram
okay so here's a better picture I claim
that what will be going for C is this
shaded parallelogram to the left of C
well let's see if I move for unit time
okay it works okay so that's the stuff
that goes for my curve in a unit time
for a small portion of carbon of course
I would need to add all of these
together to get the entire curve so
let's try to understand how big is this
parallel con so you know to know how big
this paragraph is I would like to use
base times height
or something like that and maybe I want
to actually flip my picture so that the
base and wave height make more sense to
me so let me actually turn it to this
okay and in case you have trouble
reading the rotated picture let me we do
it on the board
so what passes for a portion of C in
unit time is the contents of a
parallelogram whose base is on C so it
has length Delta s that's that's a piece
of C and the other side is going to be
given by my velocity vector F and to
find the height of this thing
I need to know well what is actually the
normal component of this vector right
so if I call n the number unit normal
vector to the curve then the area is
base times height is just so the base is
Delta s and the height is the normal
component of F so it's f dot m and so
you see that when you sum these things
together you get what I said you get
flux now if you're worried about the
fact that actually you know if your unit
time is too long then of course things
might start changing you know as the
fluid flows I mean it might so you have
to take a time unit and the length unit
that are sufficiently small so that
really this approximation where C is a
straight line and the flow is at
constant speed are valid so you know you
want to take maybe a segment here that's
like a few micrometers and you know the
time unit might be a few nanoseconds or
whatever and then it's a good
approximation
so what I mean by unit time actually
it's V you know well yeah actually that
works but now you want to think of a
really really small time and then the
amount of matter that passes in that
very very small time is the flux times
the amount of time okay let's be a tiny
bit more careful and when I'm saying
it's the amount of stuff that passes for
C well it depends actually on whether n
is going this way of a above the
opposite way so actually you know what's
implicit in this explanation is that n
counting positively all the stuff that
flows across C in the direction of N and
negatively what flows in the opposite
direction
okay so what flows to the right of C to
what well across C from left to right is
counted positively while what flows
right to left is counted negatively okay
so in fact it's the net flow for C per
unit time okay any questions about the
definition of interpretation or things
like that
yes how do you say
well you can have both not in the same
small segment but you know it could be
that well imagine that you know my
vector field you know here suddenly you
know goes in the opposite direction then
this part of the curve well things are
flowing to the left so this part of the
curve contributes negatively to flux and
here you know maybe have field is
tangent so the normal component becomes
zero and then it becomes positive and
this part of the curve contributes
positively you know for example you know
if you imagine that you have a round
tank in which the fluid is rotating and
you put your damn you know just on the
diameter across then things are going
one way and one side zero in the other
side and actually it just evens out so
we don't have complete information it's
just with total net flux okay so if
there's no other questions when I guess
we'll need to figure out how to compute
this guy and you know how to actually do
this line integral so well let's start
with a couple of easy examples okay so
let's say that C is a circle of radius a
centered at the origin going
counterclockwise and let's say that our
vector field is X I plus YJ so what does
that look like so remember X I plus YJ
is a vector field that's pointing
radially away from the origin right
because at every point it's equal to the
vector from the origin to that point so
now if we have a circle
and let's say we're going
counterclockwise so should I have a
nicer picture so let me do it here okay
so that's my curve and my vector field
and well so the normal vector see when
you go counterclockwise in a closed
curve this convention that the normal
vector points to the height of the curve
makes it point out so the usual
convention when you take flux for a
closed curve is that you're counting the
flux going out of the region enclosed by
the curve and of course if you went
clockwise it would be the other way
around you choose to do it the way you
want but we usual the most common one is
to count flux going out of your region
so let's see what happens
well if I'm anywhere on my circle see
the normal vector is sticking straight
out of a circle right that's a property
of the circle that the radial Direction
is perpendicular to the circle so
actually let me complete with this
picture if I take a point on the circle
I have my normal vector that's pointing
straight out so it's parallel to F okay
so along C we know that F is parallel to
n so f dot n will be equal to the length
the magnitude of F times well the
magnitude of n but that's one let me put
it anyway but that's a unit normal
vector now what's the magnitude of this
vector field if I'm at a point X Y well
it's square root of X square plus y
squared that's the same as the distance
from the origin okay so if this distance
if this radius is a then the magnitude
of F will just be a right so in fact if
that n is constant always equal to a so
the line integral will be pretty easy
because all I have to do is the integral
of F dot NDS becomes the integral of a
DS a is a constant so I can take it out
and integral DS is just the length of C
which is 2 pi a so I will get 2 pi a
squared ok and that is positive as we
expected because stuff is flowing out of
a circle ok any questions about that
nope okay
just out of curiosity let's say that we
had taken our other favorite vector
field so let's say that we had with same
C but now the vector field negative y
chromatics so remember that one goes
counterclockwise around the origin okay
so if you remember what we did several
times well along the circle that vector
field now is tangent to the circle so if
it's tangent to the circle it doesn't
have any normal component the normal
component is zero right things are not
flowing into the circle or out of it
they're just flowing along the circle
around and around so the flux will be
zero okay F now is tangent to C so f dot
n is zero and therefore the flux will be
zero
okay so these are examples where you can
compute things geometrically and I would
say generally speaking with flux you you
know well if it's a very complicated
field then you can't but if a field is
fairly simple you should be able to get
some general feeling for whether your
answer it it should be positive negative
or zero just by thinking about which way
is my flow going is it going across the
curve one way or the other way okay
still no questions about these examples
nope okay so next thing we need to know
is how will actually compute these
things you know because yeah here it
works pretty well but what if you don't
have a simple geometric interpretation
what if I give you a really complicated
curve and you know when you have trouble
finding the normal vector it's going to
be annoying to set up things this way so
actually there's a better way to do it
in coordinate just as you know when we
do work when we compute this line
integral usually we don't do it
geometrically like this most of the time
we just integrate MDX plus NDY
in coordinates so there's a similar way
to do it because it's again a line
integral so it should work the same way
so let's try to figure that out
okay so how do we do the calculation in
coordinates I should say maybe using
components so you know that's the
general method of calculation when we
don't have something geometric to do so
remember when we were doing things for
work we said this vector D R or if you
prefer TDS we said just become
symbolically DX and dy so that you know
when you do the line integral of F dot d
R you get line integral of M DX plus n
dy so now let's think for a second about
how we would express NDS well what is
NDS compared to TDS well n is just T
rotated by 90 degrees so NDS is TDS what
it by 90 degrees now that might sound a
little bit outrageous because you know
these are very symbolic notations but it
works so probably I'm not going to spend
too much time trying to convince you
carefully but really if you go back to
you know where we vote this and how we
try to justify this and you work your
way through it you will see that NDS can
be analyzed the same way so n is t
rotated 90 degrees clockwise so that
tells us that NDS is so how do we have't
8 a vector by 90 degrees well we swept
the two components and we put a minus
sign so swap them you have dy and DX and
you have to be careful we have to put
the minus sign well it's if you're doing
it clockwise it's in front of DX
well actually let me just convince you
quickly bike and let's say we have a
small piece of siege so if we do T Delta
s okay T Delta s that's also vector D R
if you Delta R sorry that's going to be
just you know the vector that goes along
the curve is given by this so its
components will be indeed the change in
X Delta X and the change in Y Delta Y
and now if I want to get n Delta s well
I claim now it's perfectly valid in
regards to just rotate that by 90
degrees so I lost my pipe choke it is so
if I want to rotate this by 90 degrees
clockwise then the X component will
become the same as the old Y component
and the y component will be minus Delta
X and when you take the limit when the
segment becomes shorter and shorter and
that's how you can justify this okay so
that's the key to computing things in
practice it means actually you already
know how to compute line integrals for
flux let me interest
write it explicitly so let's say that
our vector fields has two components so
let me just confuse you a little bit and
not call them MNN for this time just to
stress out you know just to stress the
fact that we are doing a different line
integral so let me call them P and Q for
now then the line integral of F dot NDS
will be the line integral of well PQ dot
product where is it dy- DX so that will
be the integral of negative Q DX plus P
demon I'm running out of space here it's
integral along c of negative Q DX plus P
dy okay and from that point onwards you
just do it the usual way namely you you
know remember here you have two
variables x and y but you're integrating
along a curve so if you integrate
another curve x and y are related they
depend on each other or maybe on some
other parameter T or theta or whatever
so you express everything in terms of a
single variable and then you do a usual
single integral okay any questions about
that I see a lot of confused faces so
maybe I shouldn't have called my
components P and Q so
okay so if you prefer okay so if you if
you you know if you really sentimentally
attached to em and n then this new line
integral becomes the integral of minus n
DX plus M dy okay so you know if a
problem tells you compute flux instead
of saying compute work the only thing
you change is instead of doing MDX plus
NDY you do - MDX plus MD way and I'm
sorry to say I don't have any good way
of helping you remember which one of the
two gets the minus sign so you just have
to remember this formula by heart that's
the only way I know well I mean you can
try to you know go for this argument
again but it's I mean it's really best
if you just remember that formula okay
so I'm not going to do an example
because we already know how to do line
integrals okay but hopefully you will
get to see one at least in recitation on
Monday okay so that's all pretty good
let me tell you now what if I have to
compute flux along a closed curve and I
don't want to compute it
so well remember in the case of work we
had greens theorem with so yesterday
greens theorem lets us replace a line
integral along the closed curve by a
double integral well here it's the same
we have a line integral along the curve
we should be able if it's a closed curve
we should be able to replace it by a
double integral so there is a version of
20 theorem for flux
and you'll see it's not more scary than
the other one is perhaps less scary or
that's just as scary or just as not
scary depending on how you feel about it
but it's it works pretty much the same
way okay so what does greens theorem for
flux see so it says if C is a curve that
encloses the region R counterclockwise
and if I have a vector field that
defined everywhere not just on C but
also inside so also an are defined well
and differentiable and so on in are well
maybe I should give names to the
components so if you'll forgive me for a
second I will still use P and Q for now
you'll see Y is defined and
differentiable in R then I can actually
replace the line integral for flux by a
double integral over R of some function
and that function is called the
divergence of F da okay so it is the
divergence of it
and they have to define for you what
this guy is so the divergence of a
vector field with components P and Q is
just P sub X plus Q sub y so this one is
actually easier to remember than curl
right because you just take the X
component take its partial with respect
to X take the Y component take its
partial with respect to Y and add them
together no signs no switching things
around this one is quite straightforward
okay so the picture again is if I have
my curve C going counterclockwise around
the region R and I want to find the flux
of some vector field F that you know is
my wine here so maybe some parts of C
will contribute positively some parts
will contribute negatively
maybe just to reiterate what I said
positively here means because we are
going counterclockwise the normal vector
points out of the region okay so this
guy here is the flux out of our [ __ ]
so that's the formula any questions
about what the statement says or how to
use it concretely no okay so it's pretty
similar to greens theorem for work so
actually I should say so maybe I should
say this is greens this is called greens
theorem in normal form also not what the
other one is abnormal but just that you
know the old one for work was you could
say in tangential form that just means
well greens theorem as seen yesterday
was for the line integral F dot T DS
integrating the tangent component of T
of F sine the one today is for
integrating the normal component of F
okay let's prove this so good news it's
much easier to prove than the one we did
yesterday because we're just going to
show that it's the same thing just using
different notations
okay so how do I prove it
well maybe actually it would help if
first before proving it I actually read
write what it means in components okay
so we said the line integral of F dot
NDS is actually the line integral of
negative Q DX plus P dy all right and we
want to show that this is equal to the
double integral of P sub X plus Q sub y
da so this looks a lot like you know
this is really one of the features of
greens theorem no matter which form it's
in it relates a line integral to a
double integral so let's just try to see
if we can reduce it to the one we had
yesterday so you know let me forget what
these things mean physically and just
focus on the math and the math it's a
line integral of something DX plus
something dy so let's call this guy m
and let's go this guy n okay so let M
equals negative Q and n equals P then I
know well this guy here becomes integral
of M DX plus n dy and I know from
yesterday what this is equal to namely
using the tangential form of greens
theorem grain for work this is the
double integral of curl of this guy's so
that's NX minus my da but now let's
think about what this is in terms of M
and n well we said that M is negative Q
so this is negative my and we said P is
the same as n so this is n X so see just
by
renaming the components I go from one
form to the other one so it's really the
same theorem that's why it's also called
greens theorem but the way we think
about it when we use it is different
because one of them computes the work
done by a force along a closed curve the
other one computes the flux maybe of a
velocity field out of a closed region
out of the out of the region okay
questions yes yeah that's correct so if
you're trying to compute you know a line
integral for flux you see it just
becomes with why do I put it so the line
integral for flux just becomes this and
once you're here you know how to compute
that kind of thing you know the double
integral side there's no even there's
not even any kind of renaming - do you
know how to compute a double integral of
function and this is just a particular
kind of function that you get out of a
vector field but it's any function you
know it's like any function the way you
would evaluate these double integrals is
just the usual way maybe you have a
function of x and y you have a region
and you set up the bounds of the I
curated integral quiet please
a lot of people talking but okay so if
the way you would evaluate the double
integrals is really the usual way by
slicing the region and setting up the
bounds for isolated integrals in you
know DX dy or dy DX or maybe Rd Rd theta
or whatever you want so in fact in terms
of computing integrals we just have two
sets of skills one is setting up
evaluating double integrals the other
one is setting up evaluating line
integrals and whether these line
integrals or double integrals are
representing work flux integral of the
curl whatever the way that we actually
compute them is the same okay
okay let's do an example oh by the way
no so first sorry
so this main aiming here
see that's why actually I called my
components P and Q because the argument
would have gotten very messy if I had
told you oh well now I call em N and
equal n minus m and so on but now that
we are done you never to f4 with this if
you still like m and n better you know
then what this says then the form you
know the formulation of greens theorem
in this language is just integral of
minus n DX plus M dy is double integral
over R of M X plus NY d ok ok so now
let's do an example let's look at this
picture again you know the flux of X I
plus y J out of a circle of radius a so
we did the calculation directly using
geometry and it wasn't all that bad but
let's see what greens theorem does for
us here
okay so example let's take the same
example as last time
so X I plus y J so see the circle of
radius a counterclockwise okay so how do
we do how do we set up greens theorem
well let's first figure out the
divergence of F unless you so so the
divergence of this field I take the X
component which is X and I take its
partial respect to X and then I do the
same with a y component and I will get
one plus one equals two
okay so the divergence of this field is
two now greens theorem tells us that the
flux out of this region is going to be
the double integral of two da where what
is our now well our is the region
enclosed by C so if C is the circle R is
the disk of radius a so of course we can
compute it but we don't have to because
double integral of two da is just twice
the double integral of DA so it's twice
the area of our and we know the area of
a circle of radius a but PI a squared so
that's 2 PI a squared that's the same
answer that we got directly which is
good news so now we can even do better
let's say that my circle is not at the
origin
you know let's say that it's out here
well when it becomes harder to calculate
the flux directly you know and it's hard
even to guess exactly what will happen
because on this side here well the
vector field will go into the
so the contribution to flux will be
negative here well here it will be
positive because it's going out of the
region
so there's positive as negative terms
what it looks like positive should win
because here the vector field is much
larger than over there but you know
computing short of computing it we won't
actually know what it is so if you want
to do it by direct calculation then you
have to parameterize this circle and
figure out you know what the line
integral will be but if you use greens
theorem well we never used the fact that
it's the circle of radius a at V origin
right it's true actually for any closed
curve that the flux out of it is going
to be twice the area of the region
inside so it will still be 2 pi a
squared
even if my circle is anywhere else in
the plane so you know if I had asked you
a trick question where do you want to
place this circle so that the flux is
allowed rest well the answer is actually
it doesn't matter now let's just finish
quickly by and so in question that some
of you I'm sure must have which is what
does divergence mean what does it
measure right I mean we said for Curl
Curl measures how much things are
rotating somehow so what does the
divergence mean well the answer is
divergence mean the variance measures
how much things are diverging ok let's
let's be more explicit so
so interpretation of divergence okay you
can think of it you know imagine that so
what do I want to say first so if you
take a vector field that just like maybe
you know that's a constant vector field
whatever thing just translate then
there's no divergence involved because
the derivatives will be zero if you take
the guy that rotates things around you
also compute and find zero for
divergence so this is not sensitive to
translation motions where everything
moves together or to rotation motions
but instead it's sensitive to expanding
motions so a possible answer is that it
measures how much the flow is expanding
ohio's okay so if you you know if we
imagine this flow that we have here on
that picture things are moving away from
the origin and we you know fill out a
plane if you imagine this fluid flowing
out there
it's occupying more and more space and
so that's what it means to have positive
divergence if you took the opposite
vector field that contracts everything
to the origin that will have negative
divergence so that's a good way to think
about it if you're thinking of a gas
maybe that can expand to fill out more
volume if you're thinking of water well
water doesn't really shrink or expand so
the fact that it's taking more and more
space actually means that there's more
and more water so the other way to think
about it
is divergence is the source weight so
it's the amount of fluid that's being
inserted into the system that's being
pumped into the system per unit time per
unit area
per unit time and per unit area so what
div F equals to here means is that here
you have actually matter being created
or being pumped into the system so that
you know you have no more water filling
more and more space as it flows but
actually divergence is not to just at
the origin it's to everywhere so in fact
to have this you need to have a system
of pumps that actually is inserting
water absolutely everywhere uniformly
that's the only way to do this I mean if
you imagine that you just have one you
know spring at the origin then sure what
I will flow out but as you go further
and further away it will do so more and
more slowly well here it's flowing away
faster and faster and that means you
know everywhere so you're still pumping
more water into it so that's what
divergence measures